Okay,
so I've had a lot of requests for a
video on the North Germanic languages,
so today I present to you a video on
Swedish,
Norwegian,
Danish,
and Finnish.
What?
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today I'm going to talk about the north
Germanic languages of the Nordic nations
that includes the Scandinavian
languages,
Swedish,
Danish,
and Norwegian,
and I will also touch on the languages
of Icelandic and federal.
Always.
I wanted to call this video at the
Scandinavian languages because I just
love the way that word sounds
Scandinavian,
but to the people of that region.
The word Scandinavian only refers to
Denmark,
Sweden,
and Norway and not to the other
countries that I want to talk about.
So if I say the Nordic nations,
that also includes Iceland,
the Faroe Islands as well as Finland.
I want to talk about the north Germanic
languages spoken in all of those
countries.
So I decided on the title that North
Germanic languages of the Nordic
nations,
and please note that finish is not in
north dramatic language.
It belongs to a separate language family
entirely.
There are about 20 million native
speakers of North Germanic languages and
that includes about 9 million speakers
of Swedish,
mainly in Sweden,
but also as a minority language in
Finland.
6 million speakers of Danish,
mainly in Denmark,
but also as a minority language in the
southern region of northern Germany and
in Greenland.
5 million speakers of Norwegian,
mainly in Norway.
Three hundred and 20,000
speakers of Icelandic,
mainly in Iceland.
90,000
speakers a feral.
We're about two thirds of them living in
the Faroe Islands and the rest of mainly
in Denmark.
The North Germanic languages are,
as you probably guessed,
a branch of the Germanic language
family.
All Germanic languages developed from
Provo Germanic,
which was spoken around 500 bce,
portage romantic possibly originated in
Scandinavia,
and different varieties of Germanic
began to emerge with migration.
Runic inscriptions from the second
century ce show us that by that time,
pro dramatic had began to separate into
distinct western,
eastern and northern dialects.
The northern dialect was spoken in
Scandinavia and is today often referred
to as pro tow norse and became the
ancestor of all the north Germanic
languages.
Poteau northwest spoken from around the
second century Ce to the eighth century
CE and by the beginning of the Viking
era in the eighth century ce,
it had evolved into dialects that are
collectively referred to as old norse.
During the next few hundred years,
vikings seafaring north people explored
much of Europe by sea and river
conquering lands and establishing
settlements and bringing their language
with them.
During this time,
old north was divided into three
mutually intelligible dialects of old
east,
north,
old west,
north and old goodness.
All the east,
northwest spoken in Sweden and Denmark
as well as their overseas settlements in
Russia,
England,
and in Danish settlements in Normandy,
old West northwest spoken in Norway as
well.
Its overseas settlements,
the two most notable where Iceland and
the Faroe Islands,
but also Ireland,
Scotland,
and the isle of Man and Norwegian
settlements in Normandy.
Old goodness was mainly spoken on the
island of Gotland,
which is today part of Sweden as well as
some overseas settlements to the east.
These west,
east and goodness varieties of old north
gradually developed into the modern
north dramatic languages around the 14th
century,
ce,
the Western branch of languages consists
of Norwegian,
Icelandic,
and feral weeds as well as some other
extinct languages.
The eastern branch consists of Swedish
and Danish.
The goodness branch consists of only the
goodness language which is still spoken
to some extent on the island of Gotland,
but these days the north dramatic
languages are generally not thought of
in terms of east,
west and goodness.
They are thought of in terms of
continental and insular.
The continental languages are Danish,
Swedish,
and Norwegian,
and the insular languages are Icelandic
and Pharaoh always.
These categories are based on mutual
intelligibility of the languages rather
than on the genetic root language that
they come from.
Norwegian is grouped with Swedish and
Danish because even though Icelandic and
Norwegian developed from the same old
west North's Norwegian is today much
more intelligible with Swedish and
Danish.
One reason for that is the political
union of Denmark and Norway from 1536 to
1814.
During this time,
the written Norwegian language stopped
being used and it was replaced by the
written Danish language and this had a
big impact on the spoken dialects of
Norwegian,
especially the central and eastern
dialects.
The continental languages also underwent
a lot of influence from middle,
low German,
which is an influence that didn't effect
Icelandic and always the three
continental languages can be referred to
as the Scandinavian languages.
When talking about the Scandinavian
languages,
it's important to note that there is a
significant amount of dialectal
variation within each language.
In fact,
the three languages are made up of a
dialect continuum.
That means if you travel in one
direction,
the dialects gradually changed.
The further you go.
That means,
for example,
that if you are Norwegian living near
the border with Sweden,
you probably have an easier time
understanding your neighbor just across
the border and Sweden.
Then you do a Norwegian from the other
side of the country.
Even though you are supposedly speaking
a different language from that Swedish
person.
This makes it kind of hard to determine
at what point these dialects become
different languages or if they are in
fact different languages at all.
The three languages are all more or less
intelligible depending on where the
dialect lies on that continuum and the
written languages are almost entirely
intelligible.
Danish seems to be the odd man out with
its complex phonology that has come to
be quite distinct from the written
language.
Swedes and Norwegians often say that
Danish people sound like they're
speaking with a potato in their mouth.
I can't actually confirm if they do
speak with a potato in their mouth,
so scandinavians,
can you let me know if that's true in
the comments down below,
I have Danish roots,
so I'm allowed to make fun of Dan's.
From what I understand,
Norwegians have the easiest time
understanding the other two Scandinavian
languages,
though they understand Swedish better
than Danish.
Swedes can generally understand or we
join,
but they have much more trouble
understanding Danish because of its
pronunciation,
and Danes can more or less understand
Norwegian and to a lesser extent they
can understand some Swedish.
From what I understand,
Scandinavians will generally not speak
the other person's language.
They will speak their own language while
making an effort to understand the other
person's speech and maybe they will slow
down and clarify things when necessary,
but when they have significant trouble
communicating,
they might switch to English,
which isn't that tough for them because
Scandinavians are magical geniuses when
it comes to learning English.
In this kind of situation where you have
three closely related languages that
kind of blended together on a continuum,
the languages are not defined by the
spoken variety,
but rather by the official standard
language associated with that country or
region.
In Denmark there is standard Danish.
In Sweden there is standard Swedish and
in Norway there is standard Norwegian or
wait,
no,
there are actually two standard
Norwegians.
That's right.
Norway actually has two official
standard written languages mall,
which means book language is a Danish
influenced standard language which is
very close to standard Danish,
but which uses Norwegian pronunciation
or new.
Norwegian is intended to be a purer
version of Norwegian based on Norway's
more conservative Western dialects,
which standard language Norwegians are
educated in.
Depends on the region they grow up in,
but despite having two official standard
languages,
Norwegians don't really speak them.
Norwegians generally speak their own
local dialect whenever they are
speaking,
even in formal situations and even when
they're speaking to people from the
other Scandinavian countries because of
this Norwegians have to get used to
understanding a wide variety of spoken
dialects and that's probably part of
what makes it easier for them to
understand Swedish and Danish,
but that of course is just my
speculation.
So native speakers,
you can confirm or disconfirm that.
So let's take a look at the three
continental languages and see just how
similar they are
in English.
I love you first and Swedish
got bang
now in Norwegian.
Now in Danish it was good.
I,
as you can see,
these sentences are very similar,
but with some differences in spelling
and pronunciation in particular,
the Swedish pronunciation is a little
different from the other to listen to
the first person singular
pronoun.
Again,
yours at the end of the Swedish one,
you can hear a hard g sound.
It's not always pronounced that way.
It depends on exactly where the speaker
is from.
Another example,
dogs are the best pets first and
Swedish.
Who's the best
next in Norwegian?
Who knows the best to share with you and
in Danish,
who knew a diversity?
Kayla,
do you.
Here we see some more noticeable
differences even though the sentences
are still really similar.
Notice the difference in the world for
dogs
who knew,
who knew the Swedish word is pretty much
pronounced as written,
but in the Norwegian and Danish words,
some letters are not pronounced and
notice the different words for pets.
The Swedish word is different from the
other two and the Norwegian and Danish
words are almost the same,
but with a different initial sound and
slightly different vowels.
Another example,
tomorrow I will go to Germany.
In Swedish
your computer
and in Norwegian you mourn Scalia Club
and in Danish you mourn scaleio to
Scotland.
In this case,
the Norwegian and Danish sentences are
basically the same,
but the sweetest sentences pronounced a
little differently.
Again,
we hear those hard g sounds which aren't
present in the Norwegian and Danish
sentences,
but again,
they're not always pronounced in Swedish
either.
One more example in English,
the party was fun because I liked the
music first in Swedish,
that's pretty young
than in Norwegian for the elite and then
Danish first show for de Kooning Seton,
and these sentences,
that preferred word for fun is different
in each language.
So the word meaning because there's also
different in Swedish and Norwegian and
Danish.
It's spelled the same but pronounced
differently and light is expressed
differently in all three languages or
the ladder with the hard g sound,
more like the voice in the recording who
newly in Danish.
It's expressed in two words.
The first one,
meaning could the phrase literally means
could suffer and listen to the
difference for the word for music in
Norwegian and Danish.
Listen to how the case sound disappears
in Danish.
And the second was Seton.
And listen to the pronunciation of this
phrase again.
Uh,
so the end of the second word seems to
vanish.
This could be part of that potato
phenomenon discussed earlier.
You can probably see just how similar
these three languages are and you can
probably see how relatively speaking
they are easy for English speakers to
learn.
They are all category one languages
according to the American Foreign
Service Institute,
which trains diplomats for their
overseas assignments.
None of the North Germanic languages are
amongst the most widely spoken languages
in the world and people from the Nordic
countries generally speak excellent
English.
So is it a waste of time to learn a
north dramatic language?
Of course not.
If you're interested in the cultures and
the history of that region,
then learning one of the languages could
bring you immense joy and because the
three Scandinavian languages are so
similar,
learning one of them can unlock the
doors to the other ones,
especially of the written languages,
and if you're an avid traveler or you
want to go backpacking around the world,
then you will probably meet in a
surprising number of Scandinavians and
knowing their language or even one of
the other two languages will help you
break the ice and get to know some
wonderful and possibly highly attractive
people.
And if you are interested in the old
Nordic cultures,
then you might benefit from learning.
Icelandic.
Since written Icelandic is still very
similar to old norse,
so don't hesitate to start learning of
the North Germanic languages,
which could be your portal into a whole
new world.
So the question of the day,
native speakers of North Germanic
languages,
what is your experience communicating
with the speakers of other languages?
Which of the other languages do you
understand the most and how do you
bridge that communication gap?
We'd like to know,
and everyone else jump in and leave
whatever comments you want.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.